>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
A BIZARRE STORY OUT OF ILLINOIS
TONIGHT WHERE A SATANIC TEMPLE
INSTALLED A DISPLAY IN THE
ILLINOIS CAPITOL NEXT TO A
NATIVITY SCENE.
THEY SAY IT REPRESENTING THEIR
SATANIC VALUES.
IT'S THE FOURTH YEAR THIS GROUP
HAS INSTALLED THE DISPLAY WHICH
FEATURES A CROCHETED SNAKE AMONG
OTHER SATANIC IMAGERY.
WHILE IN BOSTON, A MEMBER OF THE
DEAD HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION HAS
RESIGNED FOLLOWING AN UNHINGED
DIATRIBE MOCKING CHRISTIANS AMID
A LOCAL CONTROVERSY SURROUNDING
CHRISTMAS AT A LOCAL LIBRARY.
THE WOMAN WHO HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS DIANE LOUD WROTE
IN PART "IS THIS WHAT YOU THINK
YOUR MAGIC SKY DADDY WANTS?
WHERE IN THE BIBLE WAS THIS
AGAIN?
SHE'S NOT RESIGNED FROM HER
POSITION.
THANKFULLY MOST COMMON SENSE
AMERICANS APPRECIATE THE
CHRISTMAS SEASON AND THE VALUES
THAT BRING US TOGETHER INCLUDING
IMPORTANCE OF PRAYER AND THE
POWER OF FAITH.
BY THE WAY, BOTH ARE MAJOR
THEMES IN A BRAND NEW BOOK FROM
OUR VERY OWN HARRIS FAULKNER
ENTITLED "FAITH STILL
MOUNTAINS".
DEBUTING NUMBER 1 ON "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" LIST.
LATERYS JOINS US NOW.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> THANKS, SEAN.
I'M DOING FANTASTIC.
AS YOU WERE TELLING THE STORIES,
ALL I CAN THINK ABOUT IS THE
FACT THAT THE MOUNTAIN THAT
NEEDS TO BE MOVED RIGHT NOW IS
JUST THIS IDEA THAT CHRISTIANS
AND JEWS CAN BE PUSHED ASIDE BY
ANYTHING THAT PEOPLE WOULD DO.
THE WOMAN IN MASSACHUSETTS WAS
REALLY OFFENSIVE.
I DON'T JUST HOLD HER
ACCOUNTABLE GETTING ANGRY OVER
THE FACT THAT THE LIBRARY WANTED
A CHRISTMAS TREE IN HER SMALL
TOWN, WHAT ABOUT THE TOWN
COUNCIL?
WHAT ABOUT THE TOWN THAT PUT OUT
THIS STATEMENT THAT SAID SHE
QUIT?
SHE SAID SOME HORRIBLE THINGS
ABOUT THE LIBRARIAN THAT HAD
BEEN THERE 20 YEARS.
WE MISS THE CHRISTMAS TREE.
THE TOWN APPOINTED HER TO THE
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION ALTHOUGH
SHE ATTACKED THIS WITH NO
HUMANITY IN HER HEART.
SHE WENT AFTER CHRISTIANS.
SHE CALLED IT THE MAGIC SKY
DADDY WHICH IS AN OLD SCHOOL
TERM BY ATHEISTS.
YOU LOOK AT THIS AND WONDER, IS
IN RIGHT ON TIME?
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO PULL TOGETHER.
THIS IS LIKE WHEN SATAN HAS TO
SHOW THAT JOBE IS STRONG AND HIS
FAITH NO MATTER HIS
CIRCUMSTANCES.
I THINK WE CAN ALL DO THAT NO
MATTER WHAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
DOING WITH THEIR HATE.
ANY OF IT.
WE CAN STILL BE STRONG.
IT'S TIME TO BE BOLD RIGHT NOW
WITH OUR FAITH.
>> Sean: SATANISM IS ALL ABOUT
DARKNESS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT EVIL.
YOUR BOOK IS THE OPPOSITE WHERE
FAITH MOVES MOUNTAINS AND
ABOUT -- EVEN THINGS AS SIMPLE
AS LOVE GOD WITH ALL YOUR HEART,
MIND AND SOUL AND YOUR NEIGHBOR
AS YOURSELF.
VERY DIFFERENT MESSAGES.
BUT WHAT IS THEIR ARGUMENT, THAT
THIS IS THEIR RELIGION?
SATANISM?
EVIL IS THEIR RELIGION?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING, WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THAT SITUATION -- I WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE CHRISTMAS TREE AT THE
LIBRARY, WHICH IS JUST PLAIN
SILLINESS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT
NOW.
WITH THE SATANIC TEMPLE IN
ILLINOIS, THEIR MINISTER WAS
SAYING IT'S NOT THAT THEY'RE
DEVIL WORSHIPPERS.
THE WORD SATAN IN HEBREW MEANS
AVERSAR
ADVERSARY.
IT'S THE OPPOSITION TO GOD.
THEY KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT
THEY STAND FOR.
THEY HAVE PUT UP THEIR DISPLAY
NEXT TO THE SYMBOLS OF CHRISTMAS
AND THE MENORAH FOR HANUKKAH
COMING UP.
IS THIS AN ANSWER BACK IN SOME
SORT IS THE QUESTION THAT YOU'RE
ASKING, SEAN.
WE DON'T NEED AN ANSWER BACK.
WHAT WE NEED IS FOR PEOPLE TO
LEAN IN TO THEIR FAITH SO THAT
THERE IS AN AUTOMATIC SPIRITUAL
WARFARE GOING ON THERE THAT HAS
AN INPENETRATABLE WEAPON.
IT'S GOODNESS, IT'S KINDNESS AND
POWERFUL.
>> Sean: YOU SAID THIS IS THE
ASSIGNMENT OF YOUR LIFE.
I RECOMMEND "FAITH STI